i
[Música]
ah
y aquí
[Música]
cuando tenía 17 años escuché esta
historia en un momento en que se
fabricaban las mejores máscaras que se
podían hacer
el emperador anunció a su pueblo
que había llegado la hora de entregarle
el poder a su hija
las leyes establecían el matrimonio como
condición para poder gobernar
se enviaron mensajeros por todo el reino
diciendo
quien crea que tiene las condiciones
para ser el esposo de la princesa y
gobernar junto a ella preséntese en el
palacio
el día y la hora indicada
en un pueblo lejano había un hombre
sabio hermoso
y cruel
tenía el rostro desfigurado
pensó
esta es una buena oportunidad para ir a
palacio y ver que puedo probar viajo al
pueblo vecino
allí busco al mejor hacedor de máscaras
y después de amenazarlo le pidió que le
hiciera la mejor máscara que fuera capaz
de fabricar y efectivamente fue toda una
obra de arte
el mismo quedó impresionado
después de ajustarse la máscara al
rostro
viajo a la capital
y se presentó en el palacio el día
y a la hora indicada
la princesa al verlo de inmediato se
enamoró sucedió algo que nuestro hombre
no se esperaba
ser elegido como futuro esposo de la
princesa y emperador
no podía negarse a que yo podía
representar un grave peligro podía ser
ejecutado
entonces se le ocurrió una idea pidió a
la princesa un año para conocer al
pueblo y también para ir identificándose
con las funciones que como futuro
gobernante le iba a tocar desempeñar
aquello entusiasmó a la princesa de tal
manera que de inmediato aceptó
durante ese año
a nuestro hombre se le vio
saludando a la gente del pueblo
acercándose a los pobres visitando a los
enfermos reprendiendo a todos los que
cometían alguna fechoría conciliando en
las disputas pasado el año
el día antes de formalizar el compromiso
nuestro hombre tomó una decisión radical
contar la verdad se presentó al palacio
y después de confesarle a la princesa
sus verdaderas intenciones y todo lo que
había hecho ella enfurecida
decidió mandar la horca
pero le entró una curiosidad
como era el rostro de aquel hombre que
se había atrevido a presentarse a la
corte y engañarlos a todos quítate la
máscara le ordenó
el hombre asustado y solo que la
princesa le mandaba se quitó la máscara
y ella de inmediato estalló en ira eres
un embustero le dijo
asombrado le dijo qué sucede
ella le alcanzó un espejo
y oh maravilla su rostro era más hermoso
que aquel que reflejaba la máscara y es
que aquel año de estar en contacto
consigo mismo el de la compasión
había curado las heridas que llevaba en
su rostro y lo había transformado en el
verdadero ser que era y añadió el
maestro
muchas veces el más valioso lo que somos
que lo que aparentamos ser
desde entonces
nació en mí la inquietud
conocer la verdadera esencia del ser
humano motivado por la pregunta quién
soy realmente
ingresé a una comunidad religiosa
este día filosofía
literatura teología me ordene sacerdote
y finalmente después de dejar el
ministerio sacerdotal estudié psicología
y me dediqué a la terapia durante todo
ese tiempo
la pregunta que me guiaba era conocer la
profundidad delante
así que me di a la tarea de conocer qué
es la máscara
y encontré que la máscara es aquel
aspecto de nuestra personalidad con el
que queremos impresionar a los demás
también carl gustav jung dice que la
máscara es aquélla
personalidad que creamos con el fin de
adaptarnos a las demandas sociales
durante un tiempo
de estar profundizando
dije
porque nos ponemos una máscara
y encontré la razón
la primera para ocultar un dolor
profundo que todos llevamos porque nos
sentimos inadecuados en el medio en el
que nos encontramos
la segunda para obtener un beneficio
y la tercera para poder pertenecer a un
grupo para poder ser parte
lo anterior
me hizo ir a una tercera pregunta
como nos damos cuenta que estamos
viviendo desde la máscara
y entonces revisando mi historia
personal encontré
que vivimos desde la máscara cuando
empezamos a sentir que nos estamos auto
limitando en nuestro potencial en lo que
son
que la insatisfacción está tocando las
puertas de nuestra vida constantemente
y que estamos perdiendo vitalidad y
creatividad
en lo que hacemos en lo que vivimos en
lo que soñamos con todos estos
interrogantes y con todos estos
descubrimientos que había ido haciendo
llegó el 22 de enero del 2006
estaba predicando unos retiros
espirituales
era el último día
después de la charla salí a caminar por
los senderos de la casa de ejercicios
y sin darme cuenta
una voz interior me comienza a decir
francisco
qué quieres hacer con tu vida
y sin darme cuenta
empecé a responder
quiero vivir mi propia vida
aquella respuesta me asombro
no era acaso feliz en la vida que estaba
haciendo no era acaso esa la vida que yo
había elegido
sin embargo todo se volvió caos
decidí entonces hacer un proceso
terapéutico
y el terapeuta me pidió hacer una
máscara de yeso con mis propias
facciones la podía pintar con los
colores que quisiera
y debía ponerla en un lugar donde la
pudiera contemplar día y noche cada vez
que pasaba y entonces en la parte
externa de la máscara escribía todas las
cosas que la máscara representaba
y en la parte interior
podría ir escribiendo todo aquello que
yo estaba ocultando
para poder estar a la altura de las
expectativas de los otros después de
seis meses un 12 de diciembre en la
noche sentí el impulso de la
máscara la puse en el piso
salte sobre ella
y se produjo un ruido
semejante a un grito desgarrador
que estaba temblando
mire al piso
v
que aquella máscara había tomado la
forma de una mariposa y entonces me di
cuenta
para que nazca la mariposa debe morir
el gusano
ven dije todo lo que había vivido
todo lo que había experimentado
y me di cuenta que el camino recorrido
le da valor a la vida del caminante
animado
por esta fuerza que me estaba habitando
sentí como la vida estaba recuperando la
vitalidad
y como la creatividad volvía a ser parte
de mi camino fue así como decidí
abandonar el sacerdocio y reemprender el
camino para poder desprenderme de la
máscara
tuve que hacer tres cosas
la primera
agradecer desde el fondo de mi ser toda
la vida vivida y todo lo que había hecho
durante los años que había estado en la
vida religiosa
la segunda superar la vergüenza de
decepcionar a las personas en las que
había suscitado expectativas
y la tercera hacer el duelo necesario
nadie emprende un camino si antes no
sabe despedirse del camino anterior así
es
fui he ido avanzando en la vida
por eso hoy me atrevería a preguntar
qué vida es la que quieres vivir te
atreverías
a renunciar a la imagen idealizada de ti
mismo para estar en consonancia con tu
ser y con lo que deseas te atreverías a
vivir tu propia vida
muchas gracias
[Música]